- Are you interested to
get into a high profile
career like consulting or banking?
Because if you do, your
application for sure
needs to contain two documents.
First, your cover letter,
and second your CV.
So I already made some videos
talking about what it
takes to write a great CV.
And I even made one video
showing you the very CV
that I used to successfully
apply to McKinsey
as a consultant.
If you haven't seen it yet
and wanna check it out, no problem,
there's a link somewhere above
here where I will insert it.
As I got lots of positive feedback
on the video I now want to
follow it up with a second video,
showing you how the actual
cover letter looked like
that I used to successfully
apply to McKinsey in Germany.
In this video, I will walk
through paragraph by paragraph
through the cover letter that I used
for my McKinsey application.
And given that this application
was already a couple of years ago,
I will also share some reflections.
What I would probably change today
if I would now need to
write such a cover letter
because I by no means believe
that my old cover letter was perfect.
Though of course it was good enough
to get invited to the interview,
and then later also to
get me into the firm.
So welcome to another coffee
break here on my channel
Firm Learning, my name is Heinrich,
and on my channel I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
Now, before we jump into the cover letter,
now for the sake of transparency,
I did a couple of changes.
So first I translated the
whole cover letter in English
because I applied in German.
And then also took out
some personal information
just to protect my privacy
and I also changed some
minor details also just to protect myself.
But overall these changes are rather minor
so you can treat it as the
actual cover letter that I used.
But now let's jump into it.
So I have the cover
letter here in front of me
and indeed now let's go over
it paragraph by paragraph.
And first of all,
make sure that you start your cover letter
with a formal letterhead that is formative
just in the way that is
customary for your region.
So usually this will
look something like this.
So you start with your own
name, with your address
in the top right.
Then later the recruiter name,
then the company name,
and then the office
address of the company.
Here it's always great to
include the actual name
of the recruiter that will
then read your application.
Usually if you Google
the head of recruiting
or something like that, this
will be possible for you.
And this makes it always
a bit more personal
than just writing the company name.
And it shows that you did a
minimal amount of research
just here in the beginning.
Then it is customary to include
the location and the date
here in the right-hand
side of the cover letter.
And then it's good practice
to include a subject line
at the beginning of your
cover letter in bold,
just to make it clear what
this letter is all about.
So here I wrote application
for a consulting internship
position at McKinsey & Company.
Because when I applied to
McKinsey, I applied as an intern.
And then after the internship
I got a full-time offer.
So this is how I got in.
So then clearly state the objective
of your letter here in
such a subject line.
Next you formally address your recruiter.
And then you start with
the first paragraph
of the actual application.
Now probably one of the
things that I've seen
most people do wrong,
if people send me cover letters
and just ask me to review them.
And this will be what you write
in the very first paragraph.
In the spirit of top-down communication,
and if you do not know what
top-down communication is
I made a video about that.
I will link at somewhere above here.
But in the spirit of
top-down communication,
do yourself a favor and in
the very first paragraph,
very precisely state what you want.
And in the case of an application,
I would strongly recommend
you to always include
three key pieces of information.
So the first is what is the position
that you are applying to.
So in my case, this was here
the business analyst intern position.
The second information should
be what is the office location
that you are applying to?
What office would you
be interested to join?
And then third, clearly
state your availability.
So when do you wanna do the internship?
When do you wanna start
for full-time position?
And if it is for an internship,
indeed also clearly state
what the time duration
is that you wanna do.
And of course here make sure
to check the requirements
of your firms because many
firms have a minimum duration,
or sometimes also maximum duration
that an internship can take.
So make sure that you
meet these requirements
when you phrase it here
in the first paragraph.
So these are key information
to take in for any recruiter.
So don't hide information like this
somewhere in the middle of your body,
but make sure to include this
in the very first paragraph.
Next, provide some context
where you currently stand
in your life, so in your
educational journey,
on your career journey.
So if you are a student, right,
what you're currently studying,
and also when do you expect to graduate.
Because this of course will
be relevant information.
When you are an experienced hire,
so here clearly state whether
you are currently employed or not.
And if you are employed,
when you could quit the job,
when you could quit the company.
So just make it really
clear for the recruiter
where you currently
stand in your educational
or professional journey,
to have them put you into the right box.
So here I wrote about that
I was currently at the time
studying at the University of Munich.
I told them when I expected to graduate,
I told them what I was currently studying
and also tried here to make
a link to how my studies
relate now to the requirements of the job.
Now let's move to the third paragraph.
And here in the third paragraph,
I would recommend you to
now pull out one or two key
instances of experience,
key things that you did in your life
that you believe are
really the cherry on top
of your application.
What are really the things
that you stand out for?
What is your spike?
What is the spike in your application?
No, of course this will
often also be included
in your cover letter,
but really try to find something
that now the recruiter can
take and use as an information,
if they want to defend your case,
what is really the punchline,
why they should invite
you to an interview.
So here now I talked about
a special study program
that I attended in Munich.
It is quite a renowned
program in Munich at least.
And then I also told them how this really
relates to the job.
So talking about these project
based activities that I did,
and also linking it to an
internship at Accenture,
at another consulting
firm that I did earlier.
And here the important phrase to remember,
that you should really have in
your mind is show don't tell.
So what many people do wrong
is they tell in their cover letter,
they tell in their CV, instead of showing.
So what this means is
they will write things
like I am smart, I am a great team player,
I am creative, I think out of the box.
So people pretty much
just make bold claims
about themselves.
But the problem with this is
of course that talk is cheap.
Everybody can just write
things like that into their CV
or into their cover letter.
No way this really distinguishes
you from other candidates.
So instead of making cheap
claims about yourself,
rather show what you're capable of doing,
mention the specific things
that you did that really portray
these virtues that you
can bring to the table.
So instead of just talking
about how you would be great in
project based environments,
just rather show the actual
experiences that you already
collected, where you worked in projects,
where you delivered impact,
where you showed that you can bring
all these virtues to the table.
And now looking critically
at my cover letter
I think that this paragraph
is not strong enough.
So if you read this,
while this might be great
and some nice achievements,
this is now not something that
leaves you in complete awe,
this just doesn't sound
like a super awesome
and great achievement.
So that time, if I would rewrite it today,
I would dig even deeper
into what the real spikes
in my profile are that I really wanna show
here to the recruiters.
So now just to do a very short break here,
because if you find this to be helpful,
I now have a new offering for you.
Because I put together
a cover letter template
that is very similar to this cover letter.
So you get a cover letter
very similar to this
in an open Microsoft Word format
with a couple of additional remarks
that will help you to
write your cover letter.
So this would help you as a starting point
to put your own cover letter together,
check out the link in
the video description
to my cover letter template.
I hope this will be of value to you,
but now back to my cover letter.
So what I did here in my fourth paragraph
is that I talked about another key quality
that I believe that I would
be able to bring to the table
based on my past experience.
So pretty much a mirror
of the third paragraph,
but bringing in another
point, another spike
that I believe would have really helped me
in the application.
So specifically I wanted to
stress some experiences of mine
in the client service,
just to show that I would be able to face
and handle difficult client
situations on the job.
Again now, when I read this today,
probably I would have
written something else
in this fourth paragraph,
and this is rather to make
it more about motivation.
So, but this is okay if you
have really something strong
that you want to share,
probably it's a good
idea to talk a little bit
also about what actually motivates you
to become a consultant.
Why do you wanna do this job?
And then also why you
chose this specific firm
over other firms, right?
So for instance, if you apply
to BCG, or Bain, or McKinsey,
what is your motivation to
specifically apply to that firm
over some other firms.
And here now if you believe
that you have no clue
why you wanna pick that specific firm,
I would recommend you to talk
to some alums of these firms.
They will easily be able to
tell you some very specific
things that make this firm very special,
and then this is indeed
what you can write.
But here also the truth
is that the recruiters
are very much aware of the
companies like McKinsey,
BCG, or Bain.
To some extent they are pretty similar
so the expectation is not
that now you will come up
with some crazy points here right.
But of course, it's
always just nice to show
that you have some real
passion for a company.
People just love to read that,
why their own firm is special.
So just dig deep here a bit,
just to come up with some
nice and thoughtful points.
Now in the last paragraph,
I will talk about what
the next step would be
from your perspective.
So what would you like them to do now?
What is your ask now?
And of course in a recruiting context,
usually next step is then to
be invited to an interview.
So yeah, I would write exactly that,
write that you will be
glad for an opportunity
to introduce yourself in an interview.
And then the recruiter can
use this to make a reference
to that when they contact you.
So let me now share three key reflections
and recommendations that I can give you
regarding your cover letter.
First, you need to realize
that the cover letter
is a hygiene factor.
Pretty much nobody gets invited
because their cover letter
is so awesome, so don't
freak out about it.
Follow this basic clean, simple structure,
and you will be fine.
Use it as a means to convey
the key pieces of information
that you wanna let the recruiter know.
And then also use it to really underline
the key strength of your profile.
Use the cover letter to
really help the recruiter
understand what the strongest aspects
of your application are.
Second, don't make the
mistake of just repeating
what is on your CV.
People will have your CV,
they will look very diligently at your CV.
So don't just in a sterile way
copy what you wrote in the CV,
but rather use the cover
letter to add some color,
to add some additional
pieces of information
that you will usually not find on your CV
and therefore to really add
value with your cover letter.
Throughout the layout, and here make sure
that your cover letter is
no longer than one page.
Nobody wants to read a
two page cover letter.
Keep it brief and simple,
and the recruiter will
be thankful for that.
And then also avoid crazy
formatting on your cover letter.
Your cover letter just
needs to be black and white.
A very simple, basic font like Arial.
Do not use any crazy formatting,
any crazy colors, anything like that.
This will for sure not help
you in your application,
keep it strictly professional
and you will be fine.
So if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel,
and also turn on the notification bell
to stay up to date on all my content.
Also, if you really wanna help
me out with the algorithm,
please leave me a comment
below in the comment section.
Of course there, you can
also ask me any questions
and I will do my very best
to answer every single one.
If you want to see even more from me
I also have an Instagram account.
My handle is firmlearning.
And also have a mailing list,
there's a signup link to that
in the video description below.
Now, if you would like to
have a little bit more help
with your cover letter,
and have this nice, simple
layout that you can use as well,
check out my cover letter template
that I provide to you in
a Microsoft Word format.
There's a link to that in the
video description as well.
I wanna take a moment and say thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
You guys are really helping
me to run this channel.
The members benefit from
all kinds of different
member only perks.
So if you are interested
to become a member
as well and support my channel,
click on the join button
that is next to the subscribe
button to see all the details,
what this is all about.
So big thank you to all you
guys who watched until the end.
I really feel honored and privileged
to have the opportunity to
make these videos for you.
I'm always super happy
to hear from you guys
if you have any feedback, or
the video was helpful or not,
so please leave a comment below.
I release a new video every week,
I will be back next Saturday.
So until then, good weekend to all of you,
and bye-bye.